[Music]
what's the latest you know mission area
secure good work doc your legend
guys Call of Duty is back and this time
no jetpacks and no wall-running World
War two doesn't count in fact the only
air-to-air combat you're gonna see in
black ops 4 is the skydive race to the
ground to find your first gun that's
right guys this week on best of we're
taking a look at Call of Duty's new
battle royale mode blackout we're gonna
start with some sick kills move on to
some gut-busting funny moments and of
course end with some unfortunate fails
that may make you want to throw your
headset across the room now let's get it
started with that good [ __ ] bang
alright alright alright he's coming dude
I got a plan you guys ready for this
[Music]
where'd he go okay oh it's another
helicopter let's get him [ __ ] you [ __ ]
I don't know why I can't get out of my
mind it's that guy
I got him through the [ __ ] door oh
and holding it
yeah
- what the others I got my god oh my god
oh now live in library
[Music]
Oh Adam okay Oh what the hell I hit it
[Music]
nice and [ __ ] nice right here now oh
yeah I hit him yes yes get out of here
get out of here quick
[Music]
three down there now those kills were
sick but let's be honest we can't all be
summit one junior nadeshot am i right
and if you're having trouble getting
that dove and black out when I
sympathize I mean all that matters is
you had fun right here are some of the
fun
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
whoa
oh my god he almost just pumped me
pulled white mana
I don't like flying
Oh add the other one of the tree
cool cool cool it's actually them I
can't believe it
trout killed Tim the tap man I don't
think it is him Thank You D kill us all
yet right you got stuck in the stem jump
you could have jump anymore he's
spamming it how did I know how did I
know I just felt that I felt the aura
bro I felt it I'm like dude I know that
trying to get you up there I know it's
gone
I know it Oh quiet feelsbadman tip
[Music]
asada
[Music]
aside circle collapse I'm gonna get to
safety
[Music]
I [ __ ] hate this goddamn gun is
awesome it's that wide range of emotions
that I think do you think it could land
on my chopper guys yo you gonna bring me
some dope like barbecue spots and I want
to go to a nice steak house - brother
vlogs are about to be lit we're good and
we could do what we said if you really
want two thousand years get the [ __ ] out
of here guys if you're getting wrecked
and black out and you're this close to
uninstalling call of duty take heart
because our next section proves that
even the pros run into a little bad luck
sometimes we got a couple of people here
get ready to [ __ ] run if we meet you
boys get ready to watch me plummet to my
death
oh I'm done oh god I don't have again
not again
oh my god hey where ya let's get moving
you stop no good you don't have one for
you okay Frank bro you got me I have a
gun so don't worry
we're going out this
[Applause]
how much damage you take if some guy
just knew booby RPGs you or maybe you
can't even shoot it if it's not locked
on might be one of those kind of rockets
should we try it all this guy this
building top player bottom floor - oh
shoot the top window bucket alright here
we go
going out get behind you tube and you
don't face the other passes door I'm
pretty sure yeah he just opened it I
don't need your [ __ ] ass dude I missed
every step I've missed every [ __ ]
shot is this right in front of us just
rolling yep I know they roll like that
remember me over oh my god oh my god are
you kidding me what bro what the [ __ ]
like come on oh my god didn't you do
something about this thing Treyarch
can we do something about the [ __ ] 9
bang hey I'm gonna get a gun and you're
gonna [ __ ] dial a little a little a
little what no right here the crotch
here open it open it
no Oh No
[Music]
right dude my Anthony key might have to
need to do I press my up to you
watch this chat want to see why you sub
to this channel right here
[Music]
I don't knock this series right next
week eyes full kill me so tell me he's
got dead silence - that's what I'm
talking about right there man huh like
dead silence should be like a little
just a hint
[Music]
okay I'm not mister he's right next to
me
eyes full tell me so tell me I just got
a blue screen
[Music]
I'm gonna have to use this broken ass
headset for there are the beta know why
you going to the mall each other as [ __ ]
it why not cuz that's why summit
you idiot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well guys that's all we got for the best
of blackout at least so far now if you
do want to see more let me know in the
comments section and also let me know if
you want to see some Call of Duty
multiplayer content proper now don't
forget to 9:00 bang the like button and
unload those double SOGs on the
subscribe button I'll see you next time
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]